the hilarious mike forbigly
[Applause]
your podcast has
literally such great brilliant comedian
minds
that are coming on and working things
out with you is still stephen colbert
judd apatow sarah silverman bill hader
like who isn't on this podcast and why
did you start it and how did you come up
with the angle because i love when they
have a hook
yeah it was a pandemic baby it was it
was this thing where
i couldn't perform in front of audiences
and and so i thought
i want to work out material it's like
you know as a community that's all you
want and so i was like okay let me just
run jokes by
friends
and so we just started doing it over
zoom and recording it and now it now
it's in person and uh yeah it's become a
thing where yeah okay it's almost
vulnerable to do that but very very
empowering i know there's nothing like
being behind the curtain of
my favorite world in the entire world
comedy
i don't know where i'd be without it i
don't know where any of us would be
without it well i do know that i also
like good and funny news a big part of
yeah you know drew's news wants to be
you know irreverent interesting
things you might not hear otherwise
because they're not the
you know really tough front lines uh
front headlines so let's hit some mike
are you ready
you're here let's do some news right
will you take it
yeah your story next we have
next we have
a man
taking a stand to get his favorite order
back at taco bell
he wants the grilled stuffed nacho these
are always so strange to me really
well when the when the chains have these
really specific things and then people
get hooked on them oh yeah they
discontinued it in 2015. this person
went nuts
uh
chris sandberg has vowed to work to work
out every single day until they bring it
back
he's been he's been at it for 500 days
wow and look at him he looks so good
oh wow he's lost he's lost like 85
pounds because they took away his
favorite chicken stuffed burrito that is
i mean you know not all superheroes wear
capes am i right this man
that is nacho ordinary diet so i'm a i'm
a i'm a i'm a pizza fanatic and i've
always had this thought
where my favorite time to eat pizza is
the moment before you fall asleep and i
was thinking you could uh take make a
menu item where you you order a pizza
and you and you time it so the delivery
guy shows up the moment before you fall
asleep and then he wraps sort of a pizza
pillow around your neck and then you do
neck rolls
until you fall
so that was an idea i had
and uh
that's my version of what he what he
wanted back i would love a pizza pillow
i would kind of like the ones you buy at
the airport yes and you just take a bite
yeah yeah i i do i and i always like
wake up with such acid reflux and i'm
like you did it to yourself yes
um but i guess taco bell um i mean would
you put this back on the menu for this
gentleman who really made a huge
commitment yes
come on taco bell you can do it bring it
back for the poor guy please
we support it this is an inflection
point i spend yes this is a tipping
point and also um uh what is it like um
hudson news maybe the pizza
uh neck supporter yeah i think the pizza
pillow is bound to happen eventually i
have such an unnatural relationship with
pizza like i'm physically drawn to it
like i wouldn't
okay maybe this is too much for daytime
i wouldn't have sex
wouldn't have sex with the pizza but if
i ate a pizza alone i wouldn't mention
it to my wife does that make sense
like like you would cheat with pizza i
broke up with pizza because pizza knows
what it did to me all right you know
what you did
[Music]